ok ladies and gentlemen gentlemen we are
back because war is over and I can't
believe that I'm sitting here doing
Press with Juliette and Kelsey together
last year are you guys staying in a
hotel room together you guys best
friends now like where do we stand
ok so we're sitting next to each other
yeah ok same bad that's ok well what
we're seeing in the show knows like you
guys are starting to gravitate but this
was like a year ago right yeah so where
have we come in the year fun a long way
yeah I mean we have to see each other
all the time
great yeah you know I think we're both
like I may be mature nice and unless
there's something going on between us
that we don't like about each other but
once we like got over all like the
Garrett Alex yeah I mean now that like
you're not into Garrett and I'm not Alex
like you don't have a tension right and
you're not your talax either right now
right you and followed him and Instagram
and you were reply to a comment saying
that you actually why oh my god wait
guys let me hear what's so nice ok so
when he blocks me I'll star 67 he
blocked your number 2 literally blocked
me he literally went to like the phone
store and blocked my numbers I can't
even start 67 are you serious what did
you do what did you do oh I just broke
up with him oh yeah what I really did
was come here
he was like joke guard in New York again
and then you're like I'm going
she got up and we okay you're just
making so many good decisions left and
right I know I love it I wasn't gonna
stick yeah I do
dramatic pause I don't want to leave
be that girl that like sounds like oh
we're over and then like it back
together cuz you are that girl I know I
know but I love you but you are yeah but
this song I'm trying to change yeah okay
I mean could you sell fairness you mean
nice Jewish boys in New York would love
to take you to me first
yeah sorry sheesh oh sorry
what about you are you single right now
are you still so from this season who
were seeing some us yeah comes next
yes until next week now can you kind of
by what happened on the beach because it
wasn't made clear did you just make out
or did you guys have sex
oh god yeah we didn't make out we kiss
because the turn it like literally looks
like we're making Alice's right was it
like someone says something you're all
just kind of like snowballs anything
like I'm finding out stuff that happen
on the beach right in in the real life
like you might have been able to get
away with it but because you're on the
TV show I can't with this girl Brianna
hosted it on snapchat which was like oh
my god I know yeah
Joey yeah like friends all right yeah
we're good
you're good we're good just like keeping
my distance yeah I like him too I agree
and what happened to that other guy from
last season who was so cute but like no
one care about him Carson Oh Carson he's
so cute
yeah they just yeah you didn't like him
L know like he's I love him as a friend
but he's like he's too much he's too
sweet for me I need a challenge yeah I
mean that's how I feel that comes into
and like stuck trying such a good friend
oh my god yeah he's so cute I'm sure
yeah he's a girlfriend alibi oh yeah
like where did you meet your boyfriend
I'm I've known him for years I've known
her for like five or six years now and
one of my best guy friends is his
next-door neighbor and introduced us and
he lives in CSTA know woods he live he's
originally from st. Louis and then he
Arizona oh damn listens going and where
do you live now cuz you were in LA yeah
it just feels like a year ago so yeah
and then now I'm living back in Florida
okay she travels all the time yeah never
for work just for consciousness oh yeah
you're content content content and
content Never Sleeps this month so
hopefully get some shoots in there
editorial or commercial commercial
honestly commercial worth is where the
money at
[ __ ] I like Kelsey you don't want to be
editorial there's no money go no I'm at
this point on my commercial I'm good
with it
party or die it's money which one oh my
god it's really good and what did they
say anything like do the girls easy
they've literally hooked me up with
Olivia kolpos manager we're so what do
you guys plans for a fashion week what
are you doing we're gonna go pull some
clothes later yeah we're gonna go do
another interview after this and but it
won't be as fun or light-hearted oh
absolutely not yeah you'll have to be
really honest yeah yeah wait I need we
did you talk to you guys about something
and I feel really passionate about it I
was actually think about starting a
petition
oh you guys I have a big problem like
the CEO Sookie is one of my favorite
shows like I'm just obsessed with it
from so many for so many reasons but I'm
really like getting to a point where I
can't deal with Pauly anymore okay for
ethical visits to remind he's a bad
person he's gonna be bad and I'm gonna
get it funny the Susan though know who's
cruel I hate when you called Chloe that
twice like I was done with him Messi's
big dinner huh like [ __ ] Ivan called
that one million times it's so hurtful
no boy to call there's a special place
in hell for boys to call girls fat like
and Pauly is like their leader you know
doesn't care he's always been like that
get off the show because he's Alex's
cousin cousin even related no they said
they're not related we need a second
cousin
were moved he has to face no one person
who like his his dad is Alex's dad's
cousin no that's right the third cousins
I don't lean OTT and you have to go they
like one thing that damaging show I such
a good question for you guys this is
from mad Mitch on Instagram
you both have kissed and done other
things with Garrett and Alex how does it
compare who's better okay
I think it depends on who you have more
feelings for yeah like I would say Kerry
and I think we were watching Garrett and
carrot kiss the other man wait what was
that comment this last episode someone
made I don't know what I was getting to
was he's not a good kisser I understand
my god wait you can't unless it was like
nervous when I kissed him and stuff or
like I don't maybe you're intimidated
you only do it once we did it a couple
times
oh there was a chance but yeah yeah I
think I have another good question from
yeah it's Abela yeah [ __ ] marry kill
she's so cute she what do marry kill
hello Alex Brandon Garrett this is hard
well case you're just angry right now
yeah that's it I don't wanna kill him I
just don't ever want to see him but it's
gonna be so hard like it's the show
she's ready I got it that's me he's like
you really want to break up and have to
see each other all the time and I'm like
what else yeah no let me just stay with
you because I see you ah yeah it's can
you get to a place where like you just
don't care anymore and it's fine I feel
like I'm getting there like my friends
all told me like you're just gonna get
to the point where you've just had it
out yeah but the opposite of sluggard on
Wednesday with me yeah what are we doing
at Valentines what do I send you right
here no no no oh but your boyfriend
won't be it down no yeah you lots of
chop-chop on doing lines okay do your
[ __ ] my retail okay I would [ __ ] your
marry BG & Co Alex
honestly I'll do that too I take that
baby would be like a ghost but I do it
parent parents have a nice house so like
for sure Mary yeah okay this is a
question from
and Sammy Daniels oh I guess they've
enjoyed mr. Crabb for Juliet are you in
kind of friends anymore if not what
happened
no we're friends we hang out all the
time yes I'm hanging out for like four
hours
but she lives here yes so that's why you
guys like garnet she's a Squatch she got
a job in the finance world so reality
and Shannon don't don't mix
unfortunately yeah also um
you and Amanda are best friends now
mm-hmm her I love her I love she's a
good friend she really is a good friend
like she goes through that for you yeah
I feel like there was definitely a piece
that we missed with the breaking of the
nose because she just doesn't seem like
the kind of gal who goes around punching
people and breaking shoes oh she is no I
bet even that's why we like her also
where she's very old footage coming from
between Karen Alex we never saw that I
don't know about that because she wasn't
on the show then that happens likes
mattis what did he care I didn't even
know I was like boycott it they had it
on film they never used cuz she wasn't
on the show right she used to make fun
of the show right yeah like oh you guys
are stupid like your little siesta key I
really don't like you just living in
your parents house doing nothing I'm
dying
oh and so many questions it's all coming
back to me now so when you guys all
watch the other like when you guys had
that show when you were watching it outs
it sounds like is that my word like I
would die well I think it's your time at
the woman appears later okay so only
like three of us were there so Kelsey
was there I'll see you Gary are around
each other all the time Thank You pops
because it is it's the most of my life
yeah yeah and I don't know why I'm like
but it was just me I see Amanda get and
Alex and palm Carson was there are some
Yugi was there yeah person's gonna
include it also um those are the tweets
real like when you guys are so like so
fiery yeah think about it like when you
watch all this stuff back like all the
emotions right yeah like I get it you
hear stuff and people are talking [ __ ]
on you and you're like oh you said that
yeah I live for the live tweets me too
I'm always refreshing I'm like
hyperventilating tweeting yeah I like
wait so this trip to Miami
Jimmy gets mad at us yes this trip to
Miami this week is so funny it's like it
seems like everyone is literally dying
to go except for you know oh yeah I was
just like cuz I know like if I would
have gone I would have gotten devoured
yeah that was a wise decision by Lois I
wait til next episode you see I don't
get a hair about other people's issues
if they don't involve me like Chloe
cares about everyone we know but that's
her role as her posture I went on that
trip like how much would blow up in my
face why would you want to even be there
anyway that's why Karen God why didn't
know Carrie we're gonna be the next room
to celebrate you because if I rub it all
honestly I can't stand her like and I
don't see that there will ever be a time
where I like her I didn't and then I
watch the show know she's so wrong and
she like pretends she's like I don't
know what she's talking about like I
don't want to know and then she says
she's literally like make up your mind
she talks like you know like those
made-for-tv movies that we used to watch
when we were like 16 year olds like
would Matt like the click yes I wasn't
she tired out but I want to ask you a
question yeah cuz like last season I
feel like you definitely were in the
villain role what and you definitely did
you get a lot of hate from Twitter yeah
last season wasn't bad it was like first
season oh I forgot there was two seasons
already the first season do you at all
empathized with Cara who is obviously
the Billy now even though she's acting
like a villain no cuz she chose it okay
yeah Julie for bad was never like really
malicious yeah yeah she just did it it
just yeah yeah it wasn't like yeah
exactly
Cara has like intent to yeah I was she's
there to hurt yeah I was just going full
- she lives here she doesn't live in New
York she lives in Jersey New Jersey so
she just comes out to film
she has like she was anemic in any chef
we got yes takea yeah oh please I know
that she hired that shop for the duis
anything it was way around that kitchen
no that whole thing was a sham sham this
is very you know profound question from
M du Bois de blah eleven Dubois why is
the back of Alex's head so
I'm never honesty's or something with
the CSD cats were like people are
obsessed like next level like the
questions like are two very very extreme
on both sides I have an answer to that
okay I just know from like things that I
know that if you lay a baby down all in
like a table for too long their their
skull is like so soft that it molds so
could be one so he was laying down on
the table a lot of I don't know that
I'll ask his mom when I see this is a
great question Juliet even though you
guys are broken up now did it ever occur
to you or did you ever just ask Alex why
he continues to talk to Cara whichever
it's like if she's annoyed for coming
around but like he's engaging I know
he's engaging um I kind of like benched
then let it go and I'm just at the point
where I'm tired of bitching and letting
it go you shouldn't even engage he likes
the attention
yes he liked and he likes to see me mad
he likes it yeah I think that's I mean
that's what he wants right likes that he
can have whatever he wants and he thinks
he can get Cara back at all times by the
way Paul will tell you he'll tell all of
us so Cara will like call Alex randomly
out of the blue like what's he doing
does he like his new girlfriend how
serious are they like straight up told
healing taps yes I don't trust her at
all yeah I'll call him for like years
like randomly like Oh heard you got a
girlfriend want to hang out like oh my
god I don't still she's a denim girl
yeah I'm telling she's literally like a
girl like the villain from my god
teenage she's not to go out yet her like
nonchalant Ness actually works oh my god
yeah like how are you what do you think
oh she's exciting and like you were
being so heated and she was so common
because she's so mad same that's like so
mad it's like are doing hair like this
affect you at all yeah it actually
doesn't care about anyone yeah there's
an incident later on this season that
the same thing did overs like cowardice
villain like I know like also our care
and Garrett real looks like I just feel
like yeah
it's still now they like yeah once you
guys are filled in when do we start yeah
probably April that is so exciting
yeah I would get how do you guys feel
about constantly being filmed in meeting
suits well they have amazing bodies no
but still it do ski the girls get my
action secured Danny don't be working
yeah this season we really didn't like I
just have to buy clothes all the time
because I'm great people that yeah I can
tree we're now yeah it won't see me
doing it yeah or like at least the same
outfit together like and then we have
somebody like theme parties I feel like
it's like get stuff for I love doing
that I love her I love dressing it
didn't party next week right what it's a
theme party enough yeah we've the gala
you can see I love I oh my god I swear
to God
someone said Greek so my dress is Greek
not even Egyptian you'd think it
wouldn't be Greek because their house
looks like I literally everyone's
wearing like black and gold and then
there's me like in like baby blue I'm
like and she watches she's like oh well
no I figure me out like before I went
and I was like oh I hate my life so I
just like my makeup Egyptian theme yeah
what about the Chloe of it all now that
you guys in real life now like up to
date you guys are close and tight are
you friendly with Chloe you guys okay
yeah we're good it's just there's a lot
of tension between us at times
especially like we're watching episode 6
episode some rough it's it hard to like
move past me friends with people and
then you go back and see something from
a year ago where they call you like a
skank or something yeah it's hard it was
hard for me but she kind of will reach
out to me and tell me you know like that
has all passed
I'm over it like I'm here for you all
this stuff that Chloe is the best at
fighting and getting back to you yes
like she has done it in real life it's
not too humble to say when she's on your
side she's like a good friend now in
real life like now she's in a really
good place like in her life like in a
relationship now you're just happy
you're like when you're not having your
meet people like all the time I mean
yeah but I'm not upset like one of my
thing but she is now like you just see
on the internet like look so good she's
really happy with her boyfriend he's so
nice like I just think now it's like
maybe she'll just exude that
this onto others yeah so we kind of do
you need the drama a little bit yeah
school um Kelsey are you still pursuing
modeling any lucrative offers has the
show helped with that or has it hurt
well no it's helped but I think also
like I've been so busy like it's just
icky filming and then also like since
then I've been traveling and like trying
to see like family back home and I'm
surgery and my dad was in the hospitals
like I've had all this crazy stuff that
I haven't had much time to like pursue
it how was your mom doing she's doing a
lot better she had like back surgery
after the season and then so now she's
doing a little bit better that's great I
saw that you were in Thailand
with Robbie hey yes you were we actually
like know him yeah like he's from well
Jackson oh yeah um Landon and siesta key
like on the show I feel like he would
try he was just on banner from Rules
offers for show so I don't think he's
like doing it I think he's trying to do
like he created bran rubella it's like
an agency that brings like different
brands and photographers and influencers
- so did you take the pics of you I was
thinking I was like did anyone stop with
you know cuz I immediately I'm like I'm
setting my background boyfriend I'm
telling everyone like oh my god cuz I
knew I was like Chelsea I was like going
into that with the ton of guys like out
of the country I was like this is
something I'm gonna wait clear right off
the bat you're like person I'm like I
have a boyfriend like blah blah where
other people they're wanting boyfriends
[Music]
Yeah right there was a really good
question to end on it's from McKenzie
sure how was your first impression
changed of one another since starting
the show now to being like best friends
okay
I remember Kelsey once told me that she
went into the show thinking we were
gonna be best friends
yeah we were worried were like she
thought already like this I thought we
were gonna get along great and then that
just backfired
well you literally slick with Alex
my chair in front of me like pattern
moment yeah we attack at the tiki bar
I don't care actually Kara can have Alex
and Gary yes all I care
honestly she'll punch Alex as long as
she just like leaves us alone yeah you
know like I don't you don't want to see
it anymore back to New Jersey yeah I
told her that I literally go leave do
you think like there's gonna be a
mainstay like is she gonna stay on the
shape you like I think she like is she
gonna get put into the intro cut to the
feeling well she hasn't been yet yet cut
her out yeah yeah yeah talk to me about
that song every time I hear it I just
like want to jump in the pool and no
because they don't make any [ __ ]
sense that's why I was listening to it
on Spotify they have the words like oh
that's what it is yeah it's very amusing
have you guys met Carly Rae no have you
spoken to her tweeted anything maybe
it's a resurrected you think she knows
that her song is on oh my gosh your
royalties alone yeah that's true it's so
good I'm surprised she wouldn't be more
like vocal about it she really should be
a little brother's about her out yeah
really like similar to Natasha
Bedingfield unwritten yeah but this song
just like and now will never not be are
these yeah oh yeah yeah no it really
just every time I hear and I'm like put
my hair in some French braids braids of
it all was doing all your guys's French
braids Chloe is really gonna hair we
have a bunch of hair girls yes yeah no
everybody's always wearing braids cuz
it's so [ __ ] hot yeah yeah I wear
extension so I don't really do the
braids Yeah right not like I don't like
people to see them yeah they're not
ready to say I have them but like you
know I don't even know no yeah it's
great yeah I don't I need hair if I did
I would tell you I didn't say my hair so
thinner I have to have a lot of hair I
had enough does not know yeah Chloe and
Kelsey go in and out extensions yeah
yeah well I just love catching up
another thing about Kara she goes in and
out taking my she literally uses my
hairdresser my makeup artist she does a
photo shoot with my she's very low-key I
mean when the girls that dry bar were
snitching on you what I was yes I
probably lied though
not really what happened like my
hairdresser did not rat on me her Chloe
Chloe's hairdresser was eavesdropping an
ongoing conversation with my hairdresser
got it got it so Chloe just is like your
hairdresser you are you and I'm like oh
I even made it was that dry barn
no it's called fresh at the salon in
Sarasota it looks like I felt like
everyone was not wanting to say that it
was driver you imagine I would be such
bad press for them yes well that's like
a hairdressers rule you can't talk [ __ ]
ya can snitch on other client now and
nme anime here having seven stitching
I'm like I'm not telling you anything
okay I don't talks about everything that
their hair done right actually the
hairdresser really talks to you okay so
es aqui is on Tuesday nights MTV nanka
is our answer yes central oh I had one
more question sorry you guys feel
competitive the girls with who has a
most Instagram followers because it's
like it's in chin it's like a race and
it changes every time you are cats mate
yeah right now how many followers do you
have
she just hit 300 Wow and what am I
getting stuff like 297 oh let's get
let's get Juliet 2 3 5 our body Rises
instagrams Juliet Porter 0 as the Owen
Porter so got my other ones taken oh
that's annoying yeah when I'm the co co
one who every form of my name was taken
I swear unless I wanted like 4y 2 very
American name like there's probably much
yeah so I'm because II Owens without any
morning to us feel free to follow
through all right
we'll be back on Monday everyone have a
great weekend
go drink bye bye